lixo vocês que quis pensam sobre surdo o
surdo é um doente
o sonho de um macaco
tudo é oprimido é a língua de sinais é
tão perto a o estudo não tem cultura
também daqui ensinar isso me ensinou
muitas coisas eu vou contar vou
compartilhar com você
toda a minha família
são turnos meu pai é turno
minha mãe é surda
minha irmã é surda alguns teu são turnos
alguns primas são turnos todos dentro de
minha casa todo todas as pessoas são
surdos só o 1
a minha cachorrinha ela o 20 ela pai ao
todo o dão a língua de sinais através
das mãos
a minha mãe eo meu pai quando em grande
com minha mãe engravidou eu nasci eu sou
o caçula da família bebezinho bem
recente e toda a família comentaram a
fazer perto olhando olhava pro meu bettú
começaram a bater palma bater o pé bate
à porta e eu não tive reação nenhuma
porque vocês sabem que todo bebê quando
bater palma tem toda criança
toda criança ela começa a chorar
mas pra minha família foi uma grande
festa porque põe uma grande vitória mais
um surdo na família e dentro de minha
casa todos como ninguém através das
através das mãos desde então o meu
bebezinho jim que é muito estranho meu
vizinho é muito estranho é muito
estranho porque sabe que meu vinho pai
ele mexe com a boca e para oito em dança
falando ao telefone fui tudo bem
pouquinho eo assustava e eu perguntei
pro meu pai que isso
meu pai falou se ele falar com a boca e
falar lá a ele em haia na cim e me fala
e você fala com as mão e ele fala com a
boca você ouve com johnny ele ouve
quando a orelha ri não linha e ele sabia
de sinai não não sabe ou cuidar do meu
vizinho cuidando puxa ele precisa de
ajuda
o corpo quando era pequeno eu vi a
pessoa com 21 tenha medo de tocar porque
se eu tocar eu poderia vir a pegar
doença aumentará falar com a boca eu não
quero
então fui crescendo foi crescendo aí ele
vive um surto comentei até rotulando
companhia de piquet tenta da cabeça teus
penn deficiente doente macaco mínimo
louco e muito muito rótulo rótulo voto
de jimki rio jim que rimar só só isso e
passei a entender que eu pertenço à
minoritária e um dia eu e minha irmã
comandar um circo
lembra que eu falei que eu aprendi com
através do nariz de palhaço e cheguei no
circo porque eu queria na risada e
começou a inauguração
um palhaço entrou em cena assim obama
lembra mapa bar todos começaram
organizada eu e minha irmã ficamos
parados em tapa não tinha graça nenhuma
e porque todos riam
foi isso que eu conheço bem é isso que é
o engraçado é só isso e combinamos eu e
minha irmã e minha irmã tem um filho foi
o único ouvinte da família que quer
dizer ele é único deficiente na família
então n ele estava pequenininho
com seis anos mais ou menos preto por
favor você vai interpretar pra mim o que
o painel fala no circo aqui
aí eu liguei meu sobrinho na embora
quando o palhaço entrou em cena e perdão
mesmo objeto blá blá blá
aí o que que ele falou o meu sobrinho
nem de pretoria e também pela empresa de
ti do rio primeiro o meu deus quem me
falou
ele falou da boa tarde eu olhei para
minha irmã ou boa tarde
então eu e minha irmã
criamos uma peta específico para pessoas
surdas para poder atacar através da
língua de sinais em podemos juntar com a
nossa cultura e começamos a apresentar a
peça de teatro todas as crianças urna
deram risada e isso em si mary me
ensinou que a educação ele me ensinou
que sobre a educação de do história da
educação dos antigos sobre surdo até
hoje o estudo nunca bebi bó a sociedade
majoritária olha olha precisamos
resolver isso precisamos fazer isso
precisa corrigir isto precisa de ouvir
precisa fazer o melhor para o sul do que
o senado e pai 40 e fala blá blá blá
até a questão da inclusão tudo com o
colocando na inclusão o protetor não tem
informação
eles tentam sobre o surdo somente a
adaptação acessibilidade não pensa o
planejamento psi pico para surdo nunca
muito as pessoas
isto de óleos academicamente pesquisador
e podem lindas palestras lindas
maravilhosas a importância da já
pensaram que tem vários vários temas
aborda hoje eu quero falar a melhorar a
educação do surdo devem perguntar para
pessoa surda
o que você quer e na educação o que
necessito acham que tudo não é um são
capazes são muito tão capaz de mana da
área o que você pudesse imaginar êxito e
surdo piloto de avião mas a lei não
permite
existe muito surdo atleta viu manda a
lei não permite porque tudo a questão na
orelha
então tem imprimido à mesa o ovo tom
sempre para baixo o outro a diferença
deve ser respeitada a cultura a língua
juntos aí sim
pode desenvolver mais até o momento
presente não tem nada eu vou fazer
melhor toma teoria você não pode fazer
isso você não pode fazer aqui na hípica
e inclusão
então o surdo pode fazer tudo muitas
coisas por exemplo hoje torq palestrando
a minha voz é uma minha irmã ela é furna
é isso
muito obrigado a uma salva de palmas